bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
soy luis muñoz desde pan ce cáliz y me
acompaña francia market la fórmula
vicepresidencial del candidato gustavo
petro que se enfrentará el próximo 19 de
junio en segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales de colombia a
la fórmula de rodolfo hernández y marel
en castillo podría ser la primera vez
que la izquierda llegue al poder sin
embargo francia márquez ha irrumpido con
mucha fuerza en la política colombiana
aunque tiene una larga historia de lucha
medioambiental desde los 13 años ya está
en 2018 cuando se convirtió en premio
goldman el premio nobel del medio
ambiente muchas gracias 'francia márquez
por estar aquí en france 24 no muchas
gracias a ustedes cubrir lo que es este
momento político de colombia que es como
el mundo ahí en medio de tanta
incertidumbre que va a pasar el próximo
domingo pero bueno qué estamos viendo en
la resistencia del poder para lograr que
la dignidad la paz la justicia social se
haga costumbre en nuestro país con el
resultado de la primera vuelta es
evidente que los colombianos quieren un
cambio uno lo representan tanto usted
como gustavo petro y el otro lo
representan también es un llamado
ciudadano el de rodolfo hernández y su
fórmula vicepresidencial
marela en castillo cree usted que esta
irrupción de rodolfo hernández ha sido
más complicada para ustedes que si
hubiese llegado federico gutiérrez el
candidato de la derecha y del
establecimiento bueno en primero es que
no creo que rodolfo hernández es un
cambio
no creo es un hombre que ha estado en la
institucionalidad y que ha jugado en la
política en la política al igual que
todo lo otro politiqueros traición así
de hecho un hombre que hoy está imputado
por corrupción a pesar que su bandera ha
sido la bandera de venderle a la gente
que va a luchar contra la corrupción
porque efectivamente ese es uno de los
grandes problemas de nuestro país pues
no es cierto no tiene la legitimidad
para hablarle a colombia de que él va a
luchar contra la corrupción gustavo
petro francia marc que no tienen
ninguna imputación hoy sobre un delito
por corrupción mientras que rol
fernández y entonces bueno si esperaba
que estuviera el 1o o cualquiera de los
otros cualquiera si estábamos
compitiendo todos y sabía que con
cualquiera teníamos que enfrentarnos en
la final sabíamos estamos seguros que
íbamos a ganar la primera vuelta como
efectivamente pasó con un triunfo
histórico gustavo petro francia marc es
bueno y el pueblo colombiano porque el
triunfo en última desde el pueblo de la
gente
sacamos 8 millones 500 mil votos en
primera vuelta y esto es un hecho
histórico
contra todo pronóstico
con amenazas encima
con intentos de atentados teniendo que
haber parado en varios momentos nuestra
campaña de no ir a varios lugares y
territorios con todo eso y con la gran
mayoría de los medios de comunicación en
contra de la hegemonía y con todo eso
ganamos
teniendo todo eso en contra teniendo
todos los mensajes que el poder
económico le ha mandado a la gente para
hacerles sentir miedo para que no
votaran por gustavo petro y francia-
márquez pues la mayoría votaron con
nosotros entonces ganamos ahora nos toca
ganó el segundo que fue rodolfo
hernández tomar el en castillo y nos
toca ahora ganarles nuevamente y
ganarles nuevamente por una razón
porque estamos seguros
roll fue hernández
va a colocar a este país peor
que lo que generó iván duque en su
gobierno el estallido social que ocurrió
la gente no se va a aguantar lo que él
está proponiendo
de las mujeres vayan a la cocina eso es
prehistórico
ya esa fase de las mujeres vuelvan a la
cocina y no hagan política eso ya está
mandado a recoger en el mundo entero
lo de lo de decirle a la gente
que los pobrecitos hay que seguirles
explotando porque es la forma en que los
ricos han vivido siempre eso es de un
miserable
pero además
es decirle a la gente voy a acabar con
la corrupción voy a acabar con el
congreso en mentiras y es mentiras
primero porque él no tiene la banca
mayoritaria del congreso este señor si
llega a ser el presidente llega imputado
al congreso y ahí le va a tocar negociar
con todos los congresistas es decir
necesita el congreso para poder gobernar
eso además de la de los
riesgos frente a la institucionalidad de
los cambios de los ministerios que está
diciendo que va a ser de bajarle el
sueldo a los maestros y maestras es un
peligro para color ustedes afirman que
colombia necesita un cambio drástico que
representan usted y gustavo petro sin
embargo en el pacto histórico en la
primera vuelta vimos como algunos
representantes de la vieja política
hacían campaña cree que esto puede ser
contradictorio por lo que usted
representa con esa novedad o frescura
bueno esto es un proceso no esto es un
proceso
mi presencia hoy en la política es
irrumpiendo la hegemonía política que
incluso en la izquierda siempre ha
estado hombre blanco de élite
privilegiado entonces mi presencia hoy
en la política es otra cosa es algo que
la gente no esperaba porque soy root y
va porque no pido permiso porque estoy
abriendo la puerta si la puerta para que
otras mujeres como yo tengan
oportunidades las puertas para que los
jóvenes así que en este país no le han
dado una oportunidad sepan que hay
oportunidades y sepan que pueden llegar
a otros espacios
entonces eso es lo que estamos haciendo
aquí y claro se ha puesto en evidencia
el racismo el machismo
toda esa forma en como esa cultura de
violencia se ha hecho yo intentado hacer
mi esfuerzo y lo he logrado mi esfuerzo
por una política del amor la política
del cuidado una política de la verdad
con honestidad hay gente que me dice que
yo no tengo cálculos políticos pues no
porque no hago cálculos sobre la vida de
la gente no hago cálculos sobre los
derechos de la gente yo no quise estar
aquí yo decidí meterme en la política
porque me cansé de ver sufrir a mi
pueblo me cansé de movilizar me
exigiéndole a unos políticos que estaban
allá que garantizarán nuestros derechos
me cansé de verles como mientras nos
movilizábamos dejando a nuestros hijos e
hijas solos en la casa a nuestros niños
solos en la casa reclamándoles agua
potable reclamando la educación
reclamando les parar la minería ilegal
ellos se nos burlaban en la cara en
cánceres y por eso estoy aquí poniéndole
la la cara a mi país diciéndole a mi
país llegó el momento de que los de
abajo gobernemos
pase lo que pase en el resultado
electoral el 19 de junio habrá una
vicepresidenta afrodescendiente que ha
pasado en colombia para llegar a este
punto
bueno hablemos de américa latina'
américa latina tiene 200 millones de
afrodescendientes
aproximadamente si tiene américa latina
en lo que tenemos de republica estados
sólo una mujer negra ha sido
vicepresidenta quejes y campbell de
costa rica no tenemos más
o sea la gente negra 200 millones no han
estado en la política por eso cuando la
gente afrodescendiente no solo de
colombia sino de brasil las mujeres que
ahora están en brasil las mujeres negras
disputando espacios de participación
política me están mirando
en el continente africano las mujeres
que están allá me están mirando porque
tienen mi misma historia mi mismo color
las mujeres de chile y uruguay de
argentina de bolivia indígena y negra
campesina me están mirando porque están
viendo un referente porque siempre nos
dijeron que este no era nuestro lugar
no olvide que a mí me dijeron que era
una igualada
que a mí me dijeron que era una
infiltrada en la política pues si me
infiltré yq y aquí estoy y soy igual a
porque quiero que mi pueblo la gente que
nunca ha tenido derecho los nadies y las
nadie les tengan derecho en este país y
eso implica que una igualada a luchar
por la igualdad de este país
y por eso voy a hacer no sólo la
vicepresidenta de colombia sino la
ministra de la igualdad
de la igualdad para todos no sólo para
unos cuantos para todos los colombianos
y colombianas
habla mucho de los nadies y realmente su
victoria podría ser
revolucionaria ya que usted ha sido
personal de limpieza que ahora en la
vicepresidencia podría mandar a aquellos
que le mandaban antes entonces mi
pregunta es cómo va a ser ese gobierno
de los nadies eso le incomoda a mucha
gente en este país de hecho desde que yo
asumí mi proceso empecé a recibir
agresiones pero cuando gustavo petro
acordamos que iba a ser su fórmula
entonces salieron todos los actos
racistas todas las agresiones amenazas
porque no conciben si la élite
privilegiada racista clasista patriarcal
de nuestro país y aún se cree que tiene
la sangre azul no concibe que una mujer
negra que debería estar en su casa
limpiando su casa cuidando su familia
ahora vaya a ser su vicepresidenta ahora
le vaya a gobernar eso no les cabe en la
cabeza están revolcándose es más yo creo
que aceptarían a gustavo petro pero lo
que más le incomoda es ver a francia
márquez una mujer negra que no habla
como ellos que hablan como la gente de a
pie
que se comporta como la gente de a pie
como los nadies y la nadie como la gente
la mano callosa eso no lo conciben cómo
van a gobernar de frente al pueblo
mirando a la gente a la cara y
construyendo de manera colectiva un
gobierno para la gente la mayoría de los
colombianos y colombianas sienten que
nunca el estado
admirado por ellos que nunca les ha
visto se sienten
hemos estado abandonados del estado
colombiano
lo que hemos podido salir adelante lo
hemos hecho por nuestra propia cuenta
pero nunca el estado ha estado presente
y aunque yo sé que siempre estuvo
presente porque él estaba en los
territorios olvidados estuvo presente
para militarizar el territorio para
sostener el conflicto armado y la
violencia para colocar a los hijos de la
gente pobre negra indígena campesina de
sectores populares a sostener una guerra
absurda que nos ha costado cientos y
millones de vidas en este país
esto lo colocaron ahí para eso y su
presencia el estado pero nunca en
términos de inversión social nunca para
llevar agua potable para llevar la
educación para llevar salud para ofrecer
oportunidades al sector empresarial a la
pequeña la mediana empresa a la
microempresa ahí el estado no estuvo
presente para darle oportunidades a esta
gente para que echara para adelante sus
economías
este es el momento entonces vamos a
hacerlo con la gente
muchísimas gracias francia
24 no gracias a ustedes y bueno
esperamos que el domingo no sólo
colombia sino el mundo entero
esté dándose cuenta que este país cambio
que este país tomó la decisión correcta
y que bueno parte de lo que vamos a
gobernar no solamente beneficiará a los
colombianos sino a la humanidad porque
este no podemos olvidar que es uno de
los territorios de los países más
biodiversos del planeta y por tanto
cuando hablamos de una economía para la
vida estamos hablando del cuidado de la
casa créanme cuando estoy yo allá en la
toma mi comunidad defendiendo un río
cuando la comunidad de pan se está
defendiendo este río está defendiendo no
sólo la vida de la gente en colombia
sino la vida de ustedes los que no son
colombianos muchas gracias francia
márquez por estar en france 24 y muchas
gracias también a nuestra audiencia
pueden seguir más contenidos como este
en france 24 y france 24 punto com
[Música]